he's got a knife he's got a knife
shocking body camera video shows the
moments leading up to a suspect
allegedly stabbing a police officer
during a mental health disturbance
it happened on October 13th in Dayton
Ohio that's when officers received a
mental health call about 29 year old
Tyler Patrick
are you off your meds
we've talked before remember responding
officers spoke to Patrick and his mother
for nearly 15 minutes working to resolve
the problem are you feeling homicidal
suicidal I don't know how I'm feeling
right now okay well that's why I'm here
to talk to you Patrick's mother told
officers he had several mental health
diagnoses and was experiencing delusions
do you want me to ask Mom what's going
on mom she's saying oh no
okay he's delusionally and you have a
history of that I don't know
no I don't
Patrick eventually told officers he
believed someone was inside the home
you're scared because you hear people in
your house okay yeah I understand yeah
that's 100 what it is okay officers
tried multiple times to de-escalate the
situation and take Patrick to a nearby
hospital
is worried about you she's not worried
she's ignoring everything around cause
she trying to get me set up because
you're not doing what you're supposed to
be doing I don't feel safe with your
medication his mother repeated she did
not feel safe with Patrick in her home
Charlie you can't stand this house with
me no more I can't do this anymore your
mother's afraid so you got to be afraid
of me yes officers eventually admitted
they did not hear voices in the home and
plan to escort Patrick to get medical
help Mom wants to help dude
we want to help you okay you need the
help as officers approached Patrick
lunged toward them and we don't want to
take you out of here please
okay and I mean please all right let's
go come on come here please several
officers wrestled Patrick to the couch
where he pulled out what appeared to be
a knife
he's got a knife he's got a knife
Patrick then allegedly stabbed officer
George cluse in the neck he now faces
charges of aggravated felonious assault
a spokesperson for the Dayton Police
Department said the responding officers
acted appropriately working to
de-escalate the situation with patients
officer close was taken to a nearby
hospital and was treated for the Stab
Wound he has since been released and is
expected to make a full recovery for the
latest developments in this case an all
things True Crime stay with long crime
Network I'm Sierra Gillespie